i will lift up mine eyes and to the
hills from whence cometh my helped
my help coming from the lord which made heaven and
earth he will not suffer thy foot to be moved he
that keepeth thee will not slumber behold he that
keepeth israel shall neither slumber nor sleep
the lord is thy keeper the lord is thy shade upon
thy right hand the sun shall not smite thee by day
nor the moon by night the lord shall preserve thee
from all evil he shall preserve thy soul the lord
shall preserve thy going out and thy coming
in from this time forth and even forevermore
i am grateful grateful to god very grateful to
him for this high and holy privilege that he is
granted to me to fellowship with you and to be a
part of this day of prayer by the youth department
of the south botswana conference it was my
high delight to visit that country a couple
of years ago i spoke in habarrone i believe
city is called and perhaps one day god will
arrange for me to return to that blessed country
and minister to his people again but for now
i don't want to take up too much time with
introductions but i must say if there's anyone
listening who is not a set of the adventists thank
you very much your presence is always a source of
delight for us and a source of honor so to anyone
listening if you are not a seventh-day adventist
thank you for joining and may the lord
torrentially bless your lives to such a
degree that you will feel the urge the holy urge
to fellowship with us again may the lord bless the
south botswana conference the youth department and
all departments may god bless his work in botswana
of course there are people listening from other
countries wherever you are may the lord bless
your countries and may the lord impress upon the
minds of your leaders this imperishable biblical
principle righteousness exalteth a nation it
also exalts the individual who practices it
before i plunge into the message i believe god
has given me wherever you are preserve reference
where you are god is not less holy because this
is being done by zoom or facebook or youtube
these electronic platforms do not dilute weaken
reduce or affect the holiness of god god is still
holy and requires reverence so wherever you
are preserve reverence monitor your children
mute your mic so that there's no interference
as god's servants try to present the messages
i also ask you to pray for me while i'm speaking
in your heart simply say lord put your words
in that man's mouth that is based
on jeremiah chapter 1 verse 9
then the lord put forth his hand and touched my
mouth and the lord said unto me behold i have
put my words in thy mouth and it is my desire
my determination to only give you god's words
favor number three this is a youth conference
i expect you to think isaiah 180 income now
let us reason together as i listened to the
testimony of one young lady who had a problem
on the right side or left side of her face she
said she did not know who god was now she does
that god is a god who says come now let us
reason together which means that the god we serve
the god to whom we pray and will pray is a
reasonable god the devil is unreasonable but god
is reasonable let us pray father in heaven thank
you for the gift of life thank you father for
the modern technology that permits us to worship
this way that permits a speaker to enter a country
without passport or documents thank you for
those who listening with an interest in your word
and with an appreciation for the power of prayer
thank you for the south botswana conference bless
the leadership of that conference dear god give to
everyone from the president down wisdom from above
that the activities of that conference may
prepare many to meet christ when he comes bless
every country represented by the listening
audience and father if someone listening has
contracted the coronavirus i ask in the name
of jesus who healed everyone who came to him
heal that person they god remove that affliction
father god i am not praying for improvement i am
praying for total healing as an expression of
your mercy and may this demonstration of mercy
in their lives draw them closer to you if we have
sinned against you forgive us because sin makes it
difficult for us to understand truth nowaday god i
humble myself before you and i ask you in the name
of jesus a name you never refuse speak through me
they god suppress my carnal nature and let my only
purpose be on my two purposes your glory and the
blessing of your people i offer this prayer from
my heart in jesus name amen if you go to luke
chapter 11 reading from verse 1 the bible says
and it came to pass that as he was praying in a
certain place when he ceased one of his disciples
said unto him lord teach us to pray as john also
taught his disciples this is an example of jesus
praying now this jesus was also god it was he
who said let there be light it was he who led
the israelites through the wilderness it was he
who appeared to moses in the burning bush it was
he who sent the templates on egypt here he is
now in human form and he feels the need to pray
and he's praying in john chapter 6 from verse 10
the chapter that records the feeling of the 5 000
the only miracle that occurs in all four gospels
verse 10 of john 6 and jesus said make the men sit
down now there was much grass in the place
so the men sat down and sat down in number
about five thousand and jesus took the loaves and
when he had given thanks in other words he prayed
he acknowledged god as the provider of food
here is jesus praying in john chapter 11 at
the tomb of lazarus from verse 41 then they
took away the stone where the dead was laid
and jesus lifted up his eyes and said father i
thank thee that thou has heard me and i knew verse
42 that thou hearst to me always here again we
have christ praying before he performs a miracle
in luke 22 from verse 41 and he was withdrawn
from them about a stone's cast and kneeled
down and prayed saying father if thou be willing
remove this cut from me nevertheless not my will
but thing be done here again we have jesus praying
in luke 22 same chapter verse 31 and the lord said
simon simon behold satan hath desired to have you
that he may sift you as wheat but i have prayed
for thee that thy faithful not jesus prayed for
the individual named the peter and so we have
several examples of jesus praying matthew chapter
14 verse 22 and straight away jesus commanded his
disciples to get into a ship and to go before him
onto the other side while he sent the multitudes
away and when he had set the multitudes away
he went up into a mountain apart to pray now
we what we have included is the individuality of
the prayer of christ he had from time to time to
separate himself from the multitudes and to pray
not just a family prayer that's proper not just
to pray with your spouse that's proper not just
a prayer with the youth that's proper but what's
foundational is the time when it is just you as
an individual praying to your god and here we have
the bible says when the evil was come he was there
alone praying with his father so jesus prayed
let's observe something else something or let's
go back to something we discovered about jesus
perhaps we didn't notice it we might have read
over it john 11 reading from verse 41 let me pray
again god of heaven and earth continue to control
my mind and every faculty needed to produce this
message in jesus name i pray amen john 11 41 then
they took away the stone where the dead was laid
and jesus lifted up his eyes and said
father i thank thee that thou has heard me
now listen to verse 42 and i knew that thou
hearst me always there is immeasurable comfort
in those words jesus said now this is christ in
his humanity i knew that thou hearst me always but
when jesus said you always hear me it is not just
god listening with his ear it is god responding
to the prayers of his son jesus christ and
christ said i know that whenever i pray you hear
and you respond now why is that significant
well it certainly was significant for peter
if we go back to luke 22 from verse 31 and the
lord said simon simon behold satan had desired to
have you that he may sift you as wheat but i have
prayed for thee who was that who prayed for peter
jesus christ the son of god who was that that
prayed for peter the same person who while he
was mad he was also god it was the one who said
let there be light who in his humanity prayed
for peter here's the word of comfort for you and
for me jesus our god is no respecter of persons
listen carefully if christ prayed for peter
christ is willing to pray for you and he has
and you may say well how did he pray for me and
when two good questions let's answer them right
now by going to the true lord's prayer when we
read matthew 6 9-13 after this manner therefore
pray our father which art in heaven hallowed
be thy name that is a model prayer the true
lord's prayer the high priestly prayer of jesus is
found in john chapter 17. let's go there now john
17 i read from the king james version of the bible
these words spake jesus verse 1 and lifted up his
eyes to heaven and said father the hour is come
glorify thy son that thy son also may glorify thee
as thou has given him power over all flesh
that he should give eternal life to as many
as thou has given him and this is life eternal
that they might know thee the only true god
and jesus christ whom thou the saint and christ
continues with this prayer what is a particular
a concern to us is verse 9 of john 17. listen
to jesus now the disciples are standing right by
as he's praying as was the case in luke 11 1 verse
9 john 17 i pray for them i pray not for the world
but for them which thou has given me for they are
thine jesus said in his prayer to his father i
am praying for these 11 disciples
standing next to me because judas was gone
he had of course you know what his mission
was to betray christ jesus is praying
i pray for them i pray not for the world but
for them which god has given me for their thigh
and all mine as i and thine are mine and i am
glorified in them jesus prayed for the disciples
you may ask how does that benefit me well
it benefits you 100 percent go to verse 20
of john 17 neither pray i for these alone but for
them also we shall believe on me through their
word now jesus says i am not only praying for
those in my presence two thousand years ago he's
not only praying for them but listen to his words
but for them also we shall believe on me through
their word now you may say well the disciples
are dead yes but the word of god is not dead
anyone who received the gospel receives the
message from one or the other of christ's servants
neither prayer eyes for these alone but for them
also which shall believe on me through their word
my listening friend young or
old this is directed to you
what i'm trying to tell you is a 2
000 years ago jesus prayed for you
and you and i read in john 11 verse 42 jesus
said and i knew that thou herest me always
consider this let's pray again father as i try
to make this clear to the young men young women
the older men all the women whom you love
grant me the language a child will understand
in jesus name i pray amen do you understand
i'm trying to tell you that god prayed for you
god the son he told this he told us in
john 11 42 the father always hears me
which means that when he said in john 11 17
sanctify them through thy truth thy word is
truth that prayer was for you because he said in
verse 20 neither pray i for these alone but for
them also we shall believe on me through their
word and saying jesus prayed for you and jesus
gives to you and to me the unbreakable assurance
that any time he prays the father hears him
neither pray i for this alone but for them also
which shall believe on me through their word the
one who said let there be light praise to you the
one who shed his blood and the blood represents
the light it was poured out by the pouring out
of the blood he prayed for you the one who said
i am the resurrection and the life he prayed
for you now i want you to take that literally
the one who said i am the way the truth and
the life he prays for you the one who said
no man cometh unto the father but by me he prayed
for you let me say it again repetition is an
effective tool of teaching jesus christ when i'm
saying this don't look around jesus prayed for you
what did he say let's look at verse 15.
well let's read 14 and 15 of john 17
may the spirit of god continue to be with me as i
try in my human weakness to deliver this message
in jesus name i pray amen i have given them thy
word john 17 14 and the world hath hated them
because they are not of the world even
as i am not of the world listen to 15.
i pray not that thou should take them out of the
world but that thou should keep them from the evil
what evil all the evil in the world including
the personification of evil the devil himself
jesus told the father keep them from the evil now
the father cannot force that on you so you and i
must cooperate with the father that he might
answer the prayer of jesus what do i mean by
that look at what jesus prayed for in john 17 17
sanctify them through thy truth thy word is truth
that's the prayer of christ and he said the father
always hears and answers his prayer we know from 1
thessalonians chapter 4 verse 3 and this is
the will of god even your sanctification the
will of god that you and i be sanctified jesus
prayed according to the will of god when he said
sanctify them through thy truth thy word is
truth which means in order for god to answer
the prayer of christ you and i must cooperate
with that prayer by studying the word of god
and obeying it that god may with gladness answer
the prayer that his son offered for you 2 000
years ago and that prayer is still powerful today
but you and i must cooperate jesus offered the
prayer the father is standing ready to answer but
you and i have to have to respond by fulfilling
the condition if sanctification is accomplished by
the word we must study and obey that word christ
object lessons page 100 paragraph 1 if studied and
obeyed the word of god works in the heart subduing
every unholy attribute this is the process of
sanctification did not jesus tell the disciples
in john 15 3 now we clean through the word
which i have spoken unto you or you are clean
through the word which i have spoken unto you the
word of god is a cleansing agent psalm 119 verse
9 wherewithal shall a young man cleanse his ways
by taking his there to according to thy word verse
11 thy word have i hid in my heart that i might
not sin against thee we go back to john 17 17
sanctify them through thy truth my word is
truth that's the prayer of christ for you
you must study his word that the father may
finally answer that prayer in your life listen
to the prayer he gave on behalf of peter but i
have prayed for thee that thy faith fail not if
jesus did that for peter he does it for you jesus
prayed that your faith will not collapse because
you're the only seventh-day adventist in your home
he has prayed that your faith will not collapse
because you're the only seventh of the
adventist on the job he has prayed that
your faith will not collapse because you are
the only seventh-day adventist in your classroom
you may be the only seventh-day adventist
in your village think that god christ prayed
that you may stay strong cooperate with him
that that prayer might be answered in your
life remember what he said in john 17 15 i pray
not the thou shalt take them out of the world we
can't just leave this world and go live on mars
this is where we live until christ comes but that
thou should keep them from the evil what evil
are you wrestling with jesus asked the father
to give you victory from me to deliver you from
it whatever it is alcohol cigarettes pornography
whatever it is jesus told the father keep that
young man from the evil and that young man is you
jesus prayed keep that young lady from the evil
that young lady is you or that young man old man
or old woman because sin does not care about age
keep them from the evil says christ in a prayer
and we know whenever he prayed the father
answered but you and i must cooperate
and so as i come to the conclusion of
these remarks let me review in his own life
jesus prayed matthew 14 22 23 luke 11 1 luke 11
22 31-32 luke 22 41 jesus prayed john 6 11 john
11 41-42 he prayed he didn't just pray casually
by the way he prayed with intensity hebrews
chapter 5 verse 7 who in the days of his flesh
when he had offered prayers and supplications
with strong crying and tears sometimes when
jesus prayed he cried no casual pray with christ
he prayed but he also prayed for you john 17 verse
9 he prayed for the disciples and his presence and
verse 20 he said i'm also praying for those who
shall receive the words of truth that's you and
he told the father in john 17 15 keep them from
the evil whatever evil is afflicting your life
jesus prayed that the father will deliver
you but you must cooperate with god
and the secret of cooperation is to study this and
obey it i thank god that jesus prayed for me and
i want his spirit to lead me always in the path
of cooperation with him that the prayer christ
offered on my behalf might be fulfilled may the
lord bless you my young friend my young brother
my young sister my older brother older sister
may the lord bless you as you receive this truth
that your savior the creator of heaven and earth
the one who said peace be still to the sea and who
rebuked the wind and the wind ceased and there
was a great calm the one who settled across it
is finished the one who said at lazarus's tomb
i am the resurrection and the life he prayed
for you and that prayer is active today as verily
as medicine is useless if it stays in the bottle
this prayer of christ will be of no
avail if it simply stays in the bible
take it into you by taking his word at you and
allow that creative word to release the power of
that prayer under the direction of the father who
always answers the prayers of jesus let's borrow
heads and pray father in heaven we thank you
dear god we cannot thank you enough that jesus
prayed for me and for my listening friends may
god let not one day go by when we forget that our
savior offered a prayer for us bless all those who
listened a particular blessing of those who were
visitors they're not sent the adventists but they
took time to be with us bless them god and haitian
the day when they will become adventists they
may be taking bible studies right now or father
impress upon them the necessity of saying yes
to truth because yes the truth is yes to jesus
bless all of the speakers to come bless
those who sing lest those who lead the
prayer sessions father bless this entire
night of prayer at the end of it may all
the glory accumulate on your worthy head but
showers with the blessings i pray in jesus name
amen